welcome to Table Talk where each week
unpack ideas and insights from Christian
theology and spirituality that help you
become a more thoughtful calm and just a
downright great human being so my name
is Brett pastor at the table a church in
Sachse Texas and today I this would be a
little more raw Table Talk than usual
I'm just gonna kind of go off the cuff
here um but I've just had a lot of
things kind of floating around in my
mind and I want to unpack um kind of
something I see happening um in just in
the last I don't know maybe ten days and
it's around the coronavirus and it's it
kind of has to do with our culture and
basically just to kind of jump to the
end um I think it seems like we are
beginning to opt for herd immunity when
it comes to the coronavirus and based
and I think we're doing that kind of
from a gut reaction um and from a false
kind of binary like an either or option
that we feel like these we have two bad
options you know either we opted for
herd immunity
aka just kind of let this virus pass
through and you know roll the dice or we
stay at home for five years and I got
that quote that number five years it's
actually something President Trump said
at his news conference on Tuesday or to
a reporter's question he basically said
look like we we we can't shut down
America we can't all stay at home for
five years and I mean of course that's
true but I think what that's doing is
feeding this sort of either/or this
these two this binary as though those
are our two options either herd immunity
like just we got to reopen America we
just got it you know sure the numbers
are still going up and forty-one of this
I don't know how many say I mean there's
roughly 41 states opening and I think
either all or almost all maybe all but
like Montana and Alaska in certain
places you know rural very rural places
the numbers are flat or increasing and
yet we're just like oh I just can't stay
home forever so or let er rip you know
that's sort of text
right now my car like and I know that
our governor he has certain ways to look
at the numbers like well but overall
test but I think of the day the slope of
positive rates in Texas going it's flat
and or kind of like this in the last
week just like Italy ticking upwards
it's like what are we doing now you say
well but you know again these are our
options and I'm like no these are not
our options in fact here's what this
would I have a shock to find like now
I've been following a guy um Thomas or
Tomas Hawaii I think it's how you say
his name wonderful he sends such good
research on this you can I've posted his
links many times but you can look up his
article on the hammer and the dance
excellent
so there's a lot of people who are
saying like look it's pretty clear the
path forward you don't have to go like
up for these you know these binaries
either Oh Joe there's nothing we can do
just you know let it run out hurt
immunity or um you know stay at home
forever like no it's very clear the path
like massive testing um
intense tracing in terms of once
someone's identified is positive okay
who did you interact with uh you know
like look at cell phone records and
things to see what stores they visit you
know like that's the way this is lots of
other countries dozens and dozens of
other countries have done this and are
beginning to reopen in a safe way
because that's the path like it's this
is what spot mind-boggling is it's
actually not like who have no idea what
to do we we do we do have an idea now
you could say well that's other
countries and it's different and I don't
even know your sources Brad okay well
what's good this go to whitehouse.gov
slash opening America and there you have
a plan from the White House on how to
open America and it's not either
you know herd immunity play it out or
jeez you gas guzzler alright that's
another video all right so it's not herd
immunity or just stay at home forever
it's not like it's very reasonable it
basically just lay
is out kind of a three-phase plan you
say okay well how do we get there well
one of the key requirements I think
again this is very reasonable is they
say before a state begins to reopen what
we would like to see is 14 days of
falling numbers you've got so a downward
trajectory 14 days of a decrease in
flu-like symptoms 14 days of a decrease
in kovat like symptoms and cases on 14
days of falling positive test rates as a
as a percentage of total tests done and
said right just in other words 14 days
of this like that's the the angle it's
pretty simple like just when the numbers
start going like that and not like that
for a day and then back up no no 14 days
like that then you can enter phase one
and phase one is like okay limit
gatherings to 10 people and if you can't
work for home work for home but if you
can't you know wear a mask in social
distance as heavily as possible right in
it it just needle lays it out very
logically very clearly in it I mean
reading through it like um it's a good
plan solid and yet here's what's
fascinating is all the states reopening
um
aren't doing that and I think it's
because we've reached this point right
in our brains of it's either we stay at
home forever or hurt immunity and so
look even though we don't want to say it
out loud it's kinda like I just can't
say how anymore I just can't do this
anymore
and so we're just sort of foolishly I
think reopening now maybe that's an
exaggeration I mean we're not just
literally well here's the thing right
like the states are saying well within
reason and we're gonna try to limit it
but what people are hearing is oh thank
god
just we can just kind of be done because
our messaging is super ambiguous because
we don't see 14 days of falling numbers
I just I it looks like it's gonna be a
hot mess so okay what what do we do with
this um I think I'll just I'll just kind
of put it like this hey look as
followers of Jesus if you consider
yourself that if not believe we don't
believe you're all folk but for
followers of Christ
oh he pretty clearly says love your
neighbor especially your sick neighbor
your weaker neighbor your poorer
neighbor you like care for your
neighbors right it's not just it's not
just me it's we right and this is pretty
this is just a clear teaching of Jesus
and if that's so and if we have other
possibilities and other ways of
reopening that aren't just opting for
herd immunity um then as followers of
Christ that's the path we have to choose
like this this should not be a moral
option for followers of Christ to just
you know throw open the floodgates in a
in a foolish way and that's not to
minimize people's economic suffering
economic hardships because again I'm not
saying stay closed for forever all right
now obviously that's not it that's not
an option
but on the reverse side we don't want to
see millions and millions and millions
of people die and that's honestly that's
potentially what we're facing I mean the
death rate in New York for example was
around 7% like 333 thousand cases and
22,000 is deaths 6 7 % that's a huge
concern like we don't want to see that
play out over and and I think governor I
don't know how to say his last name cool
no I've only seen it written down but I
think how he put it was really wise
where someone was basically saying like
look we have a lot of people suffering
you know on the economic side on the
depression anxiety side like sane and
you know at home and all that and she
just kept asking is that is that worse
than
[Music]
is that worse than death like is that
worse than people dying and I think his
point holds that as much all that stuff
matters but but it's not to the extreme
of you know three five six ten million
people in the u.s. dying not not worth
it
so all this say not my most plucky
encouraging table talk but it's as
truthful as I can be so I love you lots
you guys feel free to chime in below in
the comments
you're your own thoughts I can't promise
I'll respond to everything but you are
free to push back as you like or agree
if that's where you are
so anyway love you I'll chat with you
later